[Musique]
comme chaque semaine mickaël ce qu'il
faut retenir des rencontres et
compétitions du week end dans le
département on commence par un sport
insolite le hisse porte
je sais que vous êtes un fan un grand
fan d'un grégory de 7 des civils pour la
deuxième année consécutive un tournoi de
ea sports était organisée à l'hôtel de
ville de versailles
des dizaines de joueurs professionnels
ou amateurs se sont affrontés sur le jeu
alors stone ce jeu de cartes virtuelles
basées sur l'univers du célèbre jeu
world of warcraft est considéré
aujourd'hui comme un sport à part
entière on écoute l'un des joueurs un
mille cas el louz alias maverick au
micro de tv 60 vite j'ai pas vraiment la
presse sports mais il ya beaucoup de
similitudes c'est à dire qu'on
s'entraîne beaucoup on analyse nos
matches être capable d'être concentré
tout le long d'un match et même de
plusieurs matches quand on doit jouer
plusieurs sur une journée c'est pas
toujours quelque chose facile même bien
boire entre les matchs etc
ces deux répliques ce que tout le monde
m'a pas et qui sont très importants
qu'on veut faire la différence au tous
niveaux au total au rendez-vous encore
réuni cette année plus de 500 passionnés
une nouvelle édition devrait être
organisée l'année prochaine y compris un
sport qui devient de plus en plus
populaire il y avait également du
cyclisme sur piste ce week-end oui
grigori troisième finale de la coupe
d'hiver 2 au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
la compétition regroupait cette année
huit clubs franciliens de la catégorie
minime aux élites
l'événement est en pleine expansion il
est passé de 90 à plus de 130
participants depuis sa création on
écoute l'un des organisateurs jean
michel richer ça fait partie des
objectifs de beaucoup de coureurs et de
beaucoup de pistard et cette coupe
d'hiver fait partie de d'une très bonne
préparation et pour certains ils vont
attaquer les épreuves sur route
notamment les coureurs d'endurance pour
attaquer les épreuves sur route dans un
mois et donc c'est une excellente
préparation à la piste une nouvelle
édition devrait être organisée l'année
prochaine des manches supplémentaires
pourraient être ajoutés objectif
pérenniser l'événement dans le temps on
termine par un résultat de handball dans
le championnat de nationale 2 féminin
rien n'arrête montigny le bretonneux les
filles de denys choulet se sont imposés
pour la troisième fois consécutive en
2019 leurs victimes du jour stella sport
saint maur le score est lui sans appel
24 à 18 pour lésiner monteyne un
résultat qui permet à montils
bretons eux de s'emparer de la septième
place et de revenir à quatre points du
podium
merci michael rassurer nos
téléspectateurs lycée paso et d'autres
choses dans le sport yvelinois ce
week-end beaucoup d'autres choses
vraiment du football il y aura également
du basket y aura plein de sport et
l'ensemble de ses résultats événements à
retrouver bien sûr dans votre émission
le 7-8 sport juste après ce journal